okay well for people who are joining us
on the live stream this is a working
meeting working on features of Wolfram
language which have been tagged as
experimental but which we are trying to
get polished enough that we can consider
them going forward it's not experimental
so there's a whole variety of different
areas we're going to be covering the
first one is about interpreter
just one specific interpreter and we
currently consider that interpreter boat
but how does some find geolocation work
isn't that is fine geolocation didn't
miss multiple things right the street
address interpreter is one of the paths
that an input can take through that
because I can also take an IP address
they can it can try to do geolocation in
other ways if it's a street address then
it's going through the the street
address interpreter so something like
that right enough is that ITF or ITR f00
that's the datum well it knows that
that's kind of wild that's news to me
that's interesting the can't can't oh
that's actually I know about that
there's there was an inconsistency in
the way that geo position was handled
for when the first audience was a list
of lists it always helps Tatum and it
never had in other cases and how they
fix this by making the non-listed
version also as displayed theta what
that doesn't make sense I don't mean
that I mean this that doesn't display
the data yeah so what's the point I
think that not the point is that happens
when you when you specify a data and
such is the case for example for
interpreter so when you when you
transform something without a datum into
something with a datum and ITR F 0 is
default that we take when there's not I
don't understand this doesn't seem right
to me it seems kind of overly fussy and
if we really know you know where you are
from a street address to a level of
accuracy that depends on the datum
something is very funky so I'm just
saying I don't think that's right and we
should check that do you believe it's
affirmative ly that's correct or do you
simply know some backstory to it I tend
to think that it's correct and I know
the back story if you want I can send
you the bucket I think we need Jose if
we're going to address this as so say
you're going to join this meeting later
for something else let's loop back who's
brought who's who's in charge of this of
this interpreter
thing from project management point of
view I think this is effectively me Alan
okay I think that fine geolocation is a
is a separate thing because it involves
also some of the working with IP
addresses I think for the the street
address interpreter my suggestion was I
I think there are still improvements we
could make that I would be happier to
try and making before we call it
non-experimental but I don't think those
can happen on a version 12 time scale
okay but I mean I think we've there are
things we can do but we have other geo
things that are ahead of Street area I'm
concerned about this I think this is
funky and I think it's gonna cause us
trouble um so can we commit try and get
Jose please
I mean while Carlos sent me the bug
position used
you
this is a very recent bug yeah because I
found it my work repair so I'm making
some changes to interpret make it much
faster list inputs okay so fine let's
let's get hold of us and let's ask him
about this okay
let's move on to the next thing so I
don't object Allen to leaving this is
experimental although I don't think the
design is going to change I think it's
merely going to be um right it's just a
matter of improving the data really but
I but I think that keeping it
experimental for now lowers people's
expectations to the right level a bit
I'd like to get rid of it soon but
they're just other geo things ahead of
it right I had no idea that New York
City and Champaign were on the exact
essentially exact same latitude well
what do you know the UM okay all right
so if Jose is going to join us in a
moment then we'll wait for him otherwise
let's move on to the next item
he's on his way I just had a chat with
him okay well let's just wait for him
but then the next thing we are we
looking at wise asks card like that and
guess glob better mentioned like there
are a bunch mask singles right okay yeah
I all know it better next time okay fine
I feel like ask has not had adequate
user you know usage at this point to be
confident about it what do you guys
I agree I think that I mean I know for a
fact that there are we always find new
bugs and and also I wanted to replace
the way ask worked to be using
persistent value but I what about what
about some web sessions I mean that
should be how does how does ask relate
technicians okay oh okay let's just deal
with the the issue with your position
okay so find geolocation is now
apparently as a very recently returning
at geo position find your location is
returning at your position that has its
state of explicitly being stated this
seems overly detailed and confusing to
people what's going on something that
has changed recently is that when do we
do a conversion like geo position of
another geo position and the external
gear position has a datum then it is
preserved because it is understood that
if the user wanted it in the first place
we should preserve it so I can imagine
that what happens here is that at some
point some some part of the code is
trained to do a conversion to ITR f00
explicitly and that's why it is
preserved okay but I don't think it I
mean user in terms of user level when
you say find your location but the
street address we should not be giving a
datum I fully agree yes okay I'm just
trying to guess what the code is to him
because I know I understand but so call
Elvis has said there's a reason I mean
there's apparently a bug here which is I
don't know how to position works but for
Interpol that that would show up because
basically the default for the the
interpreter has a default datum I could
change that okay third line right I
think interpreters did not explicitly
ask for a transformation it should just
fit on whatever is given to it
yeah okay I can see the thing is that in
the restriction you can ask for a
transformation and so the default
transformation is from height here at 0
0 to y 0 at 0 0
okay so you guys need to sort this out
like there's some code puff that's
needed that doesn't sound like okay
alright let's let's move on umm I think
that's everything we needed from Jose is
that correct
um he is also here for a theorem proving
which is pretty much at the bottom but
okay so he should come back when we get
to that right okay I'll do it
thanks a lot see ya see okay so let's
talk about ask for a minute okay
again I was asking about web sessions
and what has happened to conversation
page the same I mean conversation page
and ask or and also conversation API if
we ever do that are largely the same
thing and and and since I wanted to put
some work into ask to make it use
cookies instead of like the mechanism we
have now which is less than optimal I
was waiting for basically persisting
value to expose cookies to get started
on that okay but so persistent value
that is the cookie version of persistent
value is that correct which is which is
not yet done is that correct as far as I
know not does somebody know that here do
we have whoeverís project managing that
here
I don't know who is the p.m. for ask
okay look I'm not for us for for
persistent value yes right in these
meetings we really need the project
managers for these things here that's
related project manager it's not
directly no I understand fair enough
so oh gosh we somebody should I think
Roman is the person who's working on
this is that not correct
yeah it's Roman or is it Joel who's
working on the web session stuff I think
it was mostly Roman okay could somebody
are all night you trying to see whether
you can find Roman yes
okay but so I mean to my mind
it's a little disappointing that asked
hasn't had more usage do you have a
sense of why that is I mean is it doing
the right thing I think that there are
two problems with ask one is that it's
somewhat quarantine that you know you go
step by step
so things tend to become very long yeah
there's no choice that's what you have
yeah and and so people tend to redesign
their form so that they don't need it is
Indiana it takes longer to reload the
page to do each questions once then to
basically close I'm sorry why are you
saying that because because of seven
plantation asou no no I'm just saying
that if you have like it's if you have
to reload the page every time you have a
new question and so on like what the
heck is that
yeah the heck is that now you're you're
in a urine prototype right yes yeah okay
okay that's the work I'm doing on
interpreter okay okay all right so again
if we can't get hold of Roman right now
let's just move on I agree with leaving
this stuff experimental
okay but but what I want to do is get
the roadmap for how we're getting this
how we're getting conversation page and
conversation API implemented and that
might not be you the way fine
if that something eagle could take a
look at a back she could take a look at
possibility which group is that going to
be covered by
I mean I I think that there is an
important part of this which requires
some web knowledge or at least knowledge
of you know the wager needed to be
response works I said we internally code
active objects okay um
okay well so that needs a it okay
let's understand where is this going to
be managed
okay so I think Matt K or Dominic would
be a good person to provide choice
okay so then we better bring this up in
the cloud development meeting okay who's
going to make sure that happens I I can
I'll follow
you know Raj you need to make sure that
there are project managers in these
meetings okay I'll try to figure out who
does what and yeah thank you
yeah that that's that's what we need
okay so that's it for ask I assume I'm
not getting Roman let's move on
okay what is this
so the issue with foreign control is
that there's a disconnect between the
thing you type and the thing that it
turns into the thing that it interprets
as this input field has only a single
state I'm thinking about control equal
where you have the query cleanly
separated from the thing that the query
parses - mm-hmm we don't have that
informed control what was wrong
why was form control introduced it was a
it was introduced as a wrapper to be
able to exhibit the automation that
exists and the decision of what control
to bring up for a given input is that
correct for a given input field that
correct I thought that please I think so
I mean I think that one of the ideas
were that there was no form like thing
that it could use in a manipulate and so
they were like if you wanted to have a
field that smartly interpreted the
country to display like that's different
from what okay yeah and I've been
arguing for a bit that there is a title
way to integrate things between the
control world and the forms interpret
world and that would be like in if you
think about it like input field takes
the second argument which is a domain
yes what is this this this seems does
anybody use this what is it I really
don't understand what this is doing I
don't know if anyone who uses it when
was it introduced and why
okay what is it supposed to do I think
as Carlos said it's a way it was
supposed to give us the ability to
access form controls a single control
out of a form in a manipulate bound to a
dynamic variable in some way I see but
but I think it was not ambitious enough
like if I could just say input field of
dynamic legs comma restricted country
Europe I think it would be a lot more
powerful and then well if that still
doesn't separate the the query from the
payload well that's that's not a problem
because input field can contain anything
within it and so basically after I type
Italy after the string Italy's is
interpreted that turns into the orange
blob and there is lob in the field and
then at that point interpreter is
idempotent and some input fields can
contain anything and certainly we could
architect you know we can same thing yep
we can see that the ones that have an
interpreter type if you pass Olympic
field is not the only type of thing that
a form even it's default action can put
up like for example it can if it's an
image you can have something which is a
drag you know receiver
only on the web on the front and it
still is a file name Center it's just
that we fancied up the command center on
the web but okay but again let's let's
go through this again so this is let me
just try to make a version of this that
isn't completely crazy I mean so the
structure here let's say could be
country is that right so you're saying
no no no because it's one little ball so
you get a grant an association out you
can interpret the fulfills at once so
any would say my in too late then you
have to put X somewhere I have an X
there no I mean in the list like first
argument of the list is X and then you
know I see I see I see so then where is
it quotes X that's really funky what the
heck is that
that's not what I meant I mean in my
name's made you can't in argument names
you can put variable common domain I can
choose to control so what are you saying
here so I'm saying I have a variable and
then what's the domain here
I don't remember well blue yeah what am
I supposed to do here perform good I'm
trying to dust off an example I'll send
you what I do
so far this function is crashing and
burning in
in other words put straightforwardly the
experiment of it has failed
I would agree with that
none of us can even really remember
exactly again I really want to
understand the merge the control
language with interpreter language so
many things another benefit of doing
what what Carlos suggests with input
field is that we don't run into issues
where the where we need to separate the
query from the payload which is the the
issues that are linked from this
notebook okay but so manipulate X comma
X Y doesn't that have how do you get an
input field here list X or X comma
control type input field or X comma
value okay okay so this is that's a
regular input field and it does what it
should do okay
or I can say control type arrow input
field
right fine inside the braces that would
help
okay okay so you're proposing that in
the future I mean right now if I say
manipulate X comma like country here
obviously won't do what we want but what
does it in fact do so if it does oh I
see it defaults that's really wild it
defaults the input that defaults to it's
an input field with an initial value so
put the X in another set of braces so
that you're being clear that you're not
giving it in you're not giving an
initial value you're giving a
specification yeah and close the brace
then that will error out because country
is not a valid domain to specify I see
but it could be in the sense that we
could decide that those the things which
are supported in forms could be
supported in that syntax there also we
could do and we would need to decide
what the value assigned to X would be
because in the controls world of course
it gets an association field thing which
doesn't get an association in this world
it could just be a value I think yes and
I think I think it's right that what we
should do is make input field which
right now has certain types that it
supports right yep small handful right
but those perfectly well be that second
argument could perfectly well be a spec
a full form x with the interpreter wrap
around like interpreter country it's
possible without I think it means as a
courtesy as a syntactic courtesy it
would be nice to not have to put that
wrapper yeah if you put it you we also
gain the second third arguments and the
options are fair enough okay well so who
would get that should go to parse for
tracking and it'll be a combination of
myself for the top level stuff and
someone like John or Ian for the
possibly Aaron for the backend for the
friend support okay Carlo for consulting
I wouldn't say that this doesn't just
it's not just in good feel like for
example you could have file name Center
and and slider taking turbo respects so
slider on restricted integer from your
attorney should work as European one
okay I think you're describing it's the
wrong person I think you should describe
it to par that you should write it up
mm-hmm
okay good all right let's go on so is
that it for Carlo here
let me quickly I think so yeah
all right thanks a lot color see you
later all right bye Steven etai is on
vacation so he's not here okay
so why do you think I can eyes is not
ready for primetime
I I think it is I'm not sure why it was
ever experimental to begin with okay I
think the graphic design of it is not
adequate though people have been
complaining about that let's discuss
that a bit and well and we already have
cast Billy with improving that I don't
know where is where he is on that work
but he's if he hasn't done it already
he's he's it's on his list
okay okay can somebody see if they can
find Billy and see what he has something
to say about that right now but as far
as the technology implementation it's
solid it there's no reason for it to be
experimental in my opinion okay and what
about cloud support the only thing one
can't do on cloud is interactively
ionize a thing via the mouse yes
which we're hoping we will be able to do
right but that would involve people not
in this meetings
okay so again that's probably a Matt Kay
thing to take up but I agree there's no
reason to keep I can eyes experimental
all right let's just see this graphic
design thing why was it still tagged as
experimental here why does it still say
under active development Raj can you
describe that please
I'll see you who gave the comments I
think I you know what can I make the
suggestion that you always make sure
these comments are signed oh sure okay
let's let's see tight though I just
check those very tight comments okay but
so
that's not the case that you're
currently putting things and we don't
know what the date of this comment was
either well we're putting it for
instance into the Edit menu where we're
making it a toggle rather than a one-way
street for the interaction but there's
nothing to do with icon eyes it as a
function mention is solid okay again
let's try and get Billy okay what is
this summary box data size limit this we
shouldn't discuss without etai this is
the the threshold beyond which summary
boxes automatically decide to not
include everything not include the full
this is a really nice feature I mean
it's really great that it's working
there I mean the fact that this control
for it is still experimental I don't
think it's terribly important um
okay did we find Billy or not okay we're
gonna move on to the next item here
typesetting
what on earth is this there has nothing
to do with typesetting what the heck is
this this is something to do with the
channel framework yes indeed it is the
only client for this function right now
but it is knitted under typesetting
that's why I call the typesetting what
the heck is it disable formatting it's a
function that prevents evaluation for
example inside hold complete when it's
delivered with your a message into the
channel broker client it's a completely
general name to something whose
description is that specific well it is
made very general you can use it
anywhere the ID so if I say disable
formatting and I say something like come
one over X it doesn't look very disabled
to me what's disabled about that because
the disabled formatting works only
inside hold functions it has the wrong
name then well it is it has some it may
be but the idea is that it disables only
held expressions and the idea is that
holder does not prevent state setting
you understand option why isn't this an
option to hold because hold is very logs
among other things okay yeah good blend
this is a really weird thing so this is
part of so hold complete also doesn't
disable formatting is that correct yes
yes it is correct okay but this name
disable formatting if it applies only
inside hole there's a nuts name it's an
inside hold and aside hold complete and
inside right hand side of rule delayed
everything that is held
generally from this
this is a crazy thing yeah isn't it
better to have like and a head that says
that I know you cannot do it with a net
right what do you mean if you have one
head that is all the old ol and you say
disable formatting I am sorry I think
that is enough what were you holding an
option no no no Ricardo that this the
whole point is I'm objecting to a thing
called disable formatting that is this
very specific thing that only works
inside held functions okay I mean it
works inside any held right axis you can
think of it like an input form wrapper
that is only active inside of held
expressions yes it's really a weird
thing and which evaporates immediately
when unheld-down as a without any
reference to held
I don't know etai needs to be here for
this who was was involved in building
this tight
um ego can you give any more detail you
were when we initiated this or not yes
yes most definitely
disabled health formatting or something
is inserting hold into this name sounds
good to me yeah but but it's still a
very obscure concept I mean this is
basically saying inside of hold
this is only relevant but it does not
affect the semantics so if I say
disabled held formatting here and then I
say let me do this if I say
you
okay dandy now I say release hold so the
release hold removes removes
sable formatting yes does disable
formatting break off of its own accord
yes it does yes the release hold allows
disable formatting to evaluate and by
evaluating it removes itself but does it
do anything in this case it only does
something if it's inside a held
expression yes
I don't like disabled held formatting
because the held is like an adjective
that qualifies the formatting which is
not the correct thing yes
what really is this
this is a heck if you want to prevent
Fran and from kicking in when a held
expression is displayed and prevent any
any possible issues with the dynamic be
fired vision held expression and so on
yes I understand what it's for I mean
it's a it's a whole complete complete
complete
yes yes it is a shame it can't be an
option to hold but I think it can't be
and your point is that it's also
something that occurs in
what about
interesting idea I don't know if that
really works well but but disabled
doesn't seem right either because
disabled suggests that it's a sticky
thing like set for example okay what I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah unfortunately this
would suggest that on its own it would
hold without formatting
did you understand what I'm saying yeah
in fact the case this is just
disable for matches when held you know
right
you
I'm not seeing what to do here but I
don't think disabled is the right thing
you
I mean it's input form right you're
disabling the standard form typesetting
or the traditional form type isn't
you're still getting input form types or
if you want to call it typesetting input
form formatting yes
how on earth to say that
old unformatted
you
I mean maybe one could imagine something
where there's an expression and there's
a form here because you might I mean
then you could do full form if you want
it to
you
you
you
Held's formatting seems a little bit
more sensible in terms of the meaning
here yeah I kind of like it with stink
about it
someone on our live stream is suggesting
hope without forwarding this is an alias
for hope with auto disabled formatting
on the problem with that is that we want
many different places like for example a
: greater than you know because this if
I'm not mistaken would right now do the
right thing right if I say that it will
do this whereas if I just say this it
will rather correctly do that yes so we
really need something which is its own
wrapper
the question is if somebody sees that
you
then a piece of code what would they
have any idea what it does a : greater
than held formatting of a half it's
pretty weird
how about disabled for marking
I don't think so that's
it's some kind of you know in a
wheelchair access formatting okay um
maybe a button as a second document that
allows you to specify you know what to
format and what not format that's a bit
scary because it's gonna involve
evaluation then which is what we're
trying to avoid the whole point is to
prevent evaluation leaks that come from
you know evaluation through formative
yes of course if you're using question
mark something then yes but if it's just
a bottom yeah I'm not sure we're asking
I mean I'm not sure we need to an okay
this may have been a bad suggestion on
my part because other than full form I
can't really see why that would be
important and the pattern case okay so
I'm sorry let's walk through this again
so so what this is doing
see what will the actual words be here
right now it says disables the
formatting when appears inside a held
expression
um
what would we actually say here
poof
and what about a forum type thing just
like we say input form
so the reason we don't want held of
input form is because it will stick
around right yes okay because we want
something which is when we when we you
know release the the hold it will
evaporate automatically whereas that one
does not
that is ridiculous unfortunately because
it doesn't make it clear that the form
is going to disappear when the thing is
evaluated
um
you
hmm
you
that's an interesting suggestion from
someone on the livestream hold format
you
let's remind ourselves what the various
different you know right now we have
old form which boy what a complicated
thing okay so hold form means I could
say something like one plus one here and
it will not evaluate
you
this is boys this is a complex
so this is
when held let's write down what it is
when held use input formed for
formatting
you
which is a different statement from
dunno formatting
but
and when not held evaporate yes and the
reason call it hold input form no
because the problem with that is that
it's then a form and forms don't
evaporate I mean the semantics of it
evaporating is of course kind of weird
let's just ask the question if hold I
see that an option for hold doesn't cut
it but it doesn't solve this problem
here
I mean the full version of this would be
something like without formatting when
health
but it's not when help because as soon
as it isn't held this rapper evaporates
right mm-hmm
what's another example of a rapper which
evaporates when is there another
formatting rapper that evaporates when
the thing is not held defer evaporates
on typesetting it's not quite the same
thing let's look at the fur for a second
so defer one plus one so that output
contains no reference to defer it's
clean X right but the point about that
output is I can now copy it if I'm not
mistaken and then evaluate it correct
yes and that's its primary functionality
so what does this actually do so this is
saying yeah that's a little different um
you
yeah-uh evaluated is obviously doing
something yet different
what about
you
that crazy
what is the analogy between this and
unev alyou ated
I mean that will now wait a minute why
does that do that I thought unev al you
ated why does unevaluated stick around
in that case why doesn't it evaporate
there oh I see no that just seems wrong
why does it do that works by fact
setting attributes so that f holds its
argument on evaluated then evaluates f
of x per so why would it have unev al
you ated stick around there
to understand why I'm asking only the
leaves to
values of the functions surrounding it
is called okay but but I see if in other
words if I'd said f of X blank colon
equals x and then I said F 1 evaluated 1
plus 1 then I would get 2
you
okay is this then the analogy is the
analogy unformatted I only suggested
hold unformatted just to make it clear
that it is no but is the analogy to unev
al you ate it
so what unev al you ate it does is that
temporarily sets effectively temporarily
sets the attributes so that it won't be
evaluated what this is doing is it's
it's sort of temporarily putting an
input form around it that's right I mean
this would be see this is crazy
something like that is crazy hold
unformatted is simpler yeah well what
does it mean write the words that it
would say so well in the sense and for
market and undervalue age at work in the
opposite directions in his
because unaffiliated ads hold a tribute
and the current disable formatting does
not add anything but disappears when
it's not held so it's not exactly
parallel concept well we will okay what
do you think this sentence should say
no I'm sorry that's the wrong I'm
looking at the wrong function it's a
form that disables the for hunting of
export when it appears inside held
expressions
well it's not a forum that that's an
incorrect statement it's not a forum in
the sense of input form
that's why it's not on the name yeah no
but I see a point
you
yeah um okay okay so
boy what's really confusing about this
is how it evaporates when it is not held
anymore but which is the correct
behavior
it is certainly a useful behavior
okay any further ideas on this
I think disabled fighting is just wrong
could be
and it will be really good to have some
way of indicating that this thing's
gonna disappear if it's no longer held
I mean this is the correct name Rob I
mean this is the correct sentiment
but why does that that doesn't suggest
that it will evaporate if it's no longer
held a gun
someone is asking how do you name the
result of it is unformatted yes it's
usually called input form the problem
with input form that's that means it is
it is displayed in input form but the
actual input form rapper doesn't
disappear if I just do that oh it does
disappear because it does disappear with
percent but that's a confusing thing but
that's for a different reason
wait a minute why did that not I mean
this is the prototype dope why did that
not display um blue why does that not
you're looking at the cell label yes
yeah I think that's got to be a he's got
some new cell label he things in the
prototype build and maybe he doesn't
have that case fully finished yet yeah
that's a bug because normally it would
say slash slash input form there alright
we're a little stuck on this let's
return to the previous did we manage to
find Billy for the discussion about I
can eyes
Eric mentioned that he was apparently a
doctor's appointment okay
okay someone on the livestream mentioned
a point about ionised that is something
we should discuss
they mentioned that Ethan black 86
mentions that ionised large expressions
cause notebooks to hang when opened
and claim and not a very surprising
claim and in other words if you've got a
huge pile of data in your I can eyes
what's going to happen now in the cloud
okay Lou can you comment on that for the
for the desktop well so the
interpretation box that I can eyes uses
does need to store all of the data so
the front-end does need to at least scan
through it it doesn't need to scan it
too carefully and it's possible that
it's doing more work than it needs then
it strictly needs to do well let's find
out what the I mean if we were to do for
example let's see how can we do an easy
test let's say we do we just say then we
can obviously do this test easily enough
but but just as a sense if we say I can
eyes range of 10 to the 7 okay lovely
and quick
okay now let's save that notebook
someplace um and you see what I'm going
to save this here um
[Music]
let's go
you
okay Oh what's it doing yeah well first
of all it's taking four at this this is
I think the counter that's implemented
in the in the status area goes cell by
cell this is not a case that's
particularly handled well so that should
be fixed I'll make it up for John okay
that's first thing okay so second point
here let's find out um okay so where is
this this is a first notebook
so I mean this thing should be pretty
big oops that doesn't work I guess we
have to have fun how do we get the
notebook file name
I think it's notebook file name so sorry
I was muted yes not what filing okay so
let's see file bite to count 18
megabytes okay fine all right so now
let's see we're going to close this
and I have to go hunting through my file
system here
you
okay here goes oops
you
well that wasn't particularly shabby
although the thing didn't um show up I
mean it didn't it just didn't appear if
I'm if I'm making sense right I don't
know well I just went click double-click
and nothing's happening okay and then
suddenly it appears
so I wonder what would happen if I were
to have a bunch of content here
ahead of that large cell so much so that
the lazy loading would ignore it in the
first round but I don't know how much do
I need so so this is clearly wrong
what's happening here and the fact that
the thing this is the same issue that I
that I'll chat with John about okay um
let's try it again here
okay so that loaded immediately okay so
now something interesting is gonna
happen
okay so now I'm gonna scroll down
ooh we froze okay now and now it came in
so that freeze was fairly unfortunate
I'm a making sense right especially
because the display of this is so simple
it's just the back end that's
complicated so if you were to copy it or
here to evaluate it you do need the full
interpretation box content but just to
display it you don't okay so I just did
a copy I'm gonna paste it into another
notebook ooh wow what's that oh my gosh
I'm I'm I'm spinning here probably
because the copy is doing something what
is the copy to clipboard doing here that
I can't answer okay so that's another
issue that we have to look at okay so
now the paste was immediate
since um penalty was paid on copy
somehow right and if I say slash slash
length ten million and I'm happy that
was all immediate so for some reason on
copy here there was some clipboard
convert and done so if I now do another
paste yeah its happy happy now let's
just be outrageous here let's do that
copy this could be really bad oh my gosh
my mouse is my mouse is dead well again
you're paying the penalty on copy and
it's my penalty five times six times on
copy well you have six different objects
here the friend and most likely didn't
remember that they all came from the
same yeah and then there's no reason for
it to do that that's a silly
optimization probably because who would
want the same exact thing well actually
that's not completely clear that's
that's a question is it worth hashing
these things to find out if somebody
because I can imagine a case where
somebody wants the exact same piece of
data multiple times in their notebook
see what I'm saying you know they want
the plot of this plot of it and that
plot of it and they don't want to
explicitly name it they just wanted to
be there
okay well this is not a happy thing
what's going on here it's just spinning
it's not telling me what's happening
yeah this is a case I I don't think
we've we've tested this well so so what
would you want to have happen here would
a dialog saying copy in progress be
sufficient with the same thing that we
have in the in the in the aromatic
contents oh where where we actually
described the copy as being you know a
thing in progress type thing
okay finally copied okay so now here
it's gonna it's gonna come in
instantaneously now if I do a save it's
probably gonna take a while Oh checking
0%
now what the heck is it doing right so
this is the cell-by-cell thing that I
was mentioning before now that you know
and now it's multiple cells it will at
least say which cell it's dealing with
yeah that's probably gonna take forever
because it's it's some
all right so we've identified an issue
here so the other thing with icon eyes
is to look at the reformatting of icon
eyes so I think the expectation is that
this we unmeant alized 4:12 but that we
still have a little more work to do in
terms of smoothing this issue and in
terms of the graphic design yep okay
okay let's go back for a second now that
we've had a little break let's go back
and redress the horror of without
formatting or whether whatever it's
going to be called and what did I do
with that notebook oh boy
I'm just oh well and now it's still
saving Oh big big time waste here
um because now it did the validation
again please don't forget to at least
discuss the possibility of hashing these
things so that multiple identical ones
are dealt with immediately I'll bring it
up okay um not quite sure where my other
notebook work got to and of course this
is uninterruptible which is unfortunate
um
okay let's go back to the disabled for
hunting or whatever it's called or held
without formatting um
something vanishing for me are the word
vanish is never my favorite it somehow
speaks of magic that um and I think as
soon as one says
yeah vanishing form that's I don't know
language design hackery starts starts
flashing but it is not an unreasonable
I know Robbie has had some utilities
with evaporative as a modifier oh wow
okay
yeah well that tongue sounds like better
for you know some kind of I don't know
solar salt for arms or something
dissolving horrifying this is too weird
the UM
all right so so we have not solved this
problem here
nope
I think our least
held unformatted
[Music]
because it suggests that
unfit
held I mean that's what it actually is
input form one held by the way is input
form guaranteed to not evaluate anything
doesn't input form still evaluate
dynamics it doesn't evaluate dynamics it
does allow some things to format like I
think sequence form and colon form and
other ancient things but so is that
adequate for egos use case of really not
formatting anything I mean because the
the the issue is is it guaranteed that
input form will never evaluate is it
documented that input form will never do
an evaluation
this feels like a security problem to me
yes it is
but Igor as I recall you specifically
wanted input form here in not full form
because you wanted the expressions to be
more human readable right but then this
means we must tighten up the you know
the promise of what input form is going
to be doing and whether in fact if we're
gonna use this for something in the chat
framework we've got to make sure that it
doesn't that input form you know in in
three years somebody doesn't say oh
we've got to add this thing that does a
little tiny bit of evaluation to input
form right and we've got to actually put
tests in Rodge that will be for you that
confirmed that no evaluation is
happening an input form right
look I think but form when held is the
least horrifying of the names I've seen
form still there so it implies that it
sticks no it says when held okay I mean
it's kind of clunky but this is a clunky
concept so displays expert in input form
when it when it is when it appears as
part of a held expression as a held
expression
I think that's explainable all right
that is my provisional suggestion input
form when held okay so um who's who's
dealing with this function is that a tie
or who dealt with it Oh
relate okay fine that's my suggestion
and let me give you those two lines
there I don't gonna save this whole
notebook here um let's see so the idea
is the function will work the same and
just being renamed that is correct okay
what do people think of this name I mean
we don't really use the participle form
and function names a lot held you know
we used to have two held expression but
not anymore no we don't I mean this is a
this is a messy form um
yeah an unpronounceable participant in
our livestream is is pointing out the
concept of how to input stuff war is
becoming weirdly defined with control
equals on input evaluate in place etc
yeah it's complicated um and I'm not
fully happy with this and I think giving
it a bizarre and encrusted name like
this for a somewhat bizarre function is
probably the right thing
provisionally that's what I'm suggesting
we'll probably have to talk about this
again
let us continue on to the channel
framework horror though that is you know
what I would like to talk about the chat
stuff before we talk about the channel
framework because it's our main use case
okay
I mean obviously it relies on the
channel internal framework so you know
I'm suggesting that all this stuff stays
experimental because not only are we you
know still developing features for chat
that you know we're also staring down
the possibility of this mqtt server
setup that may or may not affect how
these existing functions need to be
designed what do you mean design why
would it make any difference when when
if there's a if there's an MQTT server
instead of the node.js I I mean I don't
know all the details of what the NPD
server would bring us if it's the case
that being Wolfram language interaction
with the server is the same then that
shouldn't be a concern
okay I don't know that okay
so Who am I going to add here just to do
a little chat let's let he go
okay so yeah but that's crazy that you
have to set it up before it starts well
I need to make some signed in as me
that's what I meant because you're gonna
send it to Brian V and I don't know if I
know I may not be but you can try I mean
well so I'm setting it as text
oh goodness sake okay what is that
you
we go what is that I am trying to start
my chat it is not enabled let me see
you
some kind of complete garbage
again I have no idea I've never seen
anything like that
yeah well Raj can you comment on this
I'm just double checking on master okay
okay I do produce it on master i evil
look into it I don't know how this again
you know we really have to get this
functionality actually working properly
I mean we we do have a packet that's in
QA testing right now and they've run
across a couple minor bugs but they did
get working so you know it's a shame
that it always seems to fall over and
yeah it always fail let's take a look I
mean just to understand 4:12 for chat
this whole business about how you can't
add people to an existing chat session
is being is being fixed and will be
fixed before version 12 that's in the
packet that's interesting right now okay
and Stephen it is working in love and
three so whatever whatever the bug is
seems to be so somebody okay so this is
so it's failing in the master branch
it's failing in the prototype branch but
you claim and I'm gonna try it because I
don't necessarily believe you that it's
working in the 11:3 production build it
is I just trusted yesterday
you
okay so if I go here by the way is it
sharing
between these things
so if I go new chat here
dundun
you
okay why did it do that little
connection where it resized that window
because this is actually the same window
that you were inviting people from it
doesn't make a new window it just you're
in that same notebook so it's it's
resizing or it has to flash a window and
resizing seems less hostile than
flashing
okay no messages no messages that's a
good sign alright so in the production
version it's some okay fine so let's try
something more real here
let's try oh yeah let's try something
let's try this let's say range of
let's try sending something I can eyes
why not send a little gift pack know
that I need to do that as input right so
i how do i do input how do i paste this
as input well you can either just i mean
it's a normal notebook you could just
make an input selling paste in that
actually this my pasting is an output
cell because you just copy the whole
cell right it doesn't I didn't copy the
whole cell actually but let me try
sending that anyway okay okay and it's
still alive
let me test okay so now here why does it
have a secondary cell here that's wrong
I wasn't watching what you're doing but
yes the list the I can eyes thing did
come through lies but there was a
secondary cell that got generated here
which doesn't seem right and this
because I set this see I'm setting that
to input why is it generating oh it's
set to make and make a new cell in case
you had something okay I mean I see why
it's a prompt problem for you to enter
stuff it's selected I don't like it
where did that come from I mean why
would xxx be the prompt I mean we can we
will just make an empty cell that's
which I have to select but when you
press new cell the cell opens with a
with some kind of weird stuff in it is
that right you mean when you click one
of those buttons yes normally it didn't
have any weird stuff when I was just
running it here okay well anyways for
some reason it has weird stuff there
okay so if I say manipulate let's say
you know x squared X 0 21 something like
this okay I get a manipulate in here and
now I want to delete the manipulate
there
well actually I'm gonna reverse close it
so what happens if I do this I'm going
to send that to you
Lee it opened the reverse closed why did
it do that they just not even handled in
there yeah it's still life or mine nice
I can okay you late so it's supposed to
be I mean if I did multiple cells is
there a good reason so here if I go like
this um and then I say whatever it is
they're an I press send magnificent so
that sent that to you as a multi cell
multicellular organism so to speak yeah
I mean it you'll notice that it did do
things with the margins that is just
kind of it's maybe a little unfortunate
but we lost being out prompt well the
amount prompts are selectable you can
toggle those on and that's under the
menu in the upper right so you mean you
mean to leave them but wait a minute but
but with the genericized in our prompts
that don't have numbers why aren't we
sending those that seems like we should
be sending those I think we didn't send
those because we didn't have genericized
prompts yeah that's not a bad idea when
you write we did not have them when we
were doing this so I think that should
be the default setting is to send the
genericized prompts right it's a little
weird to send your actual prompts and
that was why we turned them off yeah
right so I think we should be sending
generous size prompts look sense okay
all right so let's go back here to what
this is okay so these are um copy
channel UUID okay what's chat settings
that's my chat settings that's
that really what um what we would want
to call that menu item just chats and it
suggests it's the chat it's for this
particular chat yeah I mean it's that's
what it's because you can access that
from the window menu or the product
level window menu as well and that's
what its close the window menu here yep
it's the fifth thing down there I see it
boy that's hard to understand out of
concept out of context I mean especially
since the word chat can also be a verb
and also the fact that settings it's not
where I expect to find settings right
I'm gonna find settings I would find
them over by the Preferences menu right
which changes around on platform from
platform to platform um
I mean on on Windows basically why not
the chat settings not just in
preferences as a separate tab I mean
they certainly could be this is just
it's kind of an experimental thing and
the Preferences menu is set in stone
we're trying to we were just trying to
keep a lower profile lower footprint and
changing well except that it's right at
the top level of a main menu now well
but it's not messing up the Preferences
dialog so to speak I think that's a lame
argument if I might say so I mean the
Preferences dialog needs some updating
anyway I think it should just be a chat
to just be a tab here I mean we already
have something something is in there for
chat and it's under services it's the
turn on and off chat at the top level
okay but but I think this should be
called chat preferences and it should go
in the Preferences dialog if you say
chat preferences I think it's more
obvious
then excuse me um more of this that it's
not settings for this particular chat
session but is a general preferences
thing do you agree or not generally I
agree but I mean even when you go to it
from inside of a chat you see things
like screen name and you might think
that you're setting your screen name for
just this chat but you're not so it's no
but okay with that that when you go into
those preferences if it's in part of the
Preferences dialog then you kind of know
that it's a global thing
oh so you alright you're so you're
saying when you selected it from chat
settings that it would open up the
Preferences dialog and navigate to that
place and the Preferences dialog where
you were changing it yes I know it
doesn't no this is fine what's doing
here is perfectly nice if it says chat
preferences I think that will be fine
maybe global references how global would
you want it to be I mean in other words
is it it's not syncing to the cloud or
anything it could and we talked about it
but it's not currently so it's not
global and nonsense right well I mean we
could indicate that by indicating the
the scope here this to the cloud what we
can indicate essentially the persistence
location in here which would then make
it clear how global it actually is makes
sense yeah makes sense and I think it
should use persistent value with a
global you know default Lee I mean it I
thought this was going to be in the you
know in the cloud right which I don't
think this is yet working in the cloud
it is not and what's the status of that
we have talked cloud folks about it but
as far as I know we're still waiting on
service link but that's in order to have
IC because the mechanism we're using
here is actually writing with notebook
commands and does notebook right
basically yeah and so right now this
would be oh well where are the
preferences here
that's really weird if I open a new
notebook
that's crazy that's crazy what just
happened there the menu should be did
you saw that
hey Raj did you see that
so you know okay let's go back to it
okay in this state here and this page is
changing right but in this state here
there's a very short menu here right
mm-hmm
as soon as I go into an actual thing
there's a big long menu which includes
preferences great okay and that's where
this should be
and by the way we need to probably unify
the Preferences that we are seeing there
with the desktop references that's
probably going to need to be a session
to go over and somebody should prep that
I think that's something probably for
between pars and Matt okay okay I'll let
them know
okay all right so
okay so when you say create chat here um
what does create chat do you might not
actually find it in product I think it
you might oh no it it's there nevermind
great but it's in some weird sub context
it is and that's because it was not
fully funny these these are all very
simple implementations they're not doing
a whole lot you can create check your
first all you have to load chat tools
package to do it in the experimental
ization item because this is not a
system context thing it should be though
if there's if this stuff was actually
fully fleshed out it the fact that it
was living in a context is really just a
temporary you know we had we wanted to
get we were discussing having a design
meeting about programmatic chat stuff
right exactly is all the functions we
need or do we need we need tons of
functions don't we yeah and there's
another one that there's functionality
for that isn't even on this list cuz
it's not documented yet like listing
your chat rooms the chat rooms that you
own or sending a message to a particular
chat room right and that's then that
stuff is all not implemented though and
also providing a bot for a chat room
right sure do we know how to do that at
this point I mean that's essentially an
API function that's called from the you
know when when you send that and that
relates also to our ask discussion from
earlier you know it should be the case
that a bot can see everything that
happened in the chat session and can
then decide what to do mm-hm
yeah and then would I mean I back when
we were first messing around with chat
stuff I wrote a little bot that was you
know basically it looked for a string
pattern that was saying to it or you
know that you sent to the channel if you
asked the bot for something it would you
know what it did is it did a some
WolframAlpha lookup on it yep and that's
I mean that at its core all about is is
something listening that's looking for
specific patterns
yes I understand but what's the
interface I mean in other words for a
given chat you have to associate a bot
with it right so it's essentially a
deployment into that channel ego have
you thought this through
No
okay whoo-hoo if anybody has thought any
of this through so I mean it could be
you know if we had a chat object which
is you know basically a wrapper around
channel object I don't think BOTS
necessarily need to be designed at the
channel framework level I mean it could
be I guess but how would it look okay so
if you have I mean so okay let's say
that you had a WolframAlpha bot it's
just something that we pre deployed for
people to use that would be some it
doesn't matter how it's but that's not
what I'm talking about what I'm talking
about a user deployable BOTS well okay
fine you're deploying it as a cloud
object it's an either an API function
something you have some cloud object and
then let me point out by the way that
the bot I mean in the current
architecture I guess the only
disembodied computation that can run is
in the cloud that is you couldn't have a
local bot server and I'd have to think
about that I'm not sure you can but
it'll go down when your session goes
down yes I understand
I mean if you had a good if you had a
computer that or if you had a machine
that would be able to listen to things
like if you could you know pass it some
special message over a channel to tell
it to listen to another channel it could
be local I don't know what couldn't be
but what eating with the same way server
of some kind but it's possible that
initially we would only support such
things in the cloud I don't be easiest I
think but then what does it look like
so you've deployed something to the
cloud and now somehow that cloud I don't
know if it's an API or whatever has to
be connected into this chat session
right so something has to tell it this
chat session I say that you you would
probably add it just like a participant
I think you just add it and and but it
would be you know under the hood it
would be specially
you know that the chat tools would know
that okay this is a bot so I need to
look for and send a special message or
so you know evaluate this API function
in this certain way that it knows to
start listening to this chat you know
you know it might just be as simple as
just passing it the UID for the channel
and then it just starts listening to it
and it knows that when it gets something
we don't have that functionality in the
cloud right now until we have triggered
tasks right trigger tasks will trigger
from a channel is that correct or ego is
there a mechanism in the in the channel
framework or would this be a channel
listener
well how does how would this work
well if it's an API function it does not
have any persistence in the sense that
it does not remember all previous
messages and so on if it's a desktop
sessions and general listen will
maintain all this history and in that
sense it's simpler for a boat to to
operate if the channel listener is
deployed locally am I making sense yes
but I don't understand the well what
you're saying there is that we don't
have a good way to maintain to show the
history I mean the ask functionality
does have a way to show the history what
is the relationship between the ask
functionality and chat I asked first I
know I need to look at it
I mean isn't that my experience with a
skits it's admittedly pretty basic - but
don't you basically have to define all
of the different trees that you yes yes
you do but but in other words yeah so
it's a little different but it's some
I mean you could you could adverse
a simple bot being defined using the ask
functionality though using the ask
framework well particularly if we have
conversation API and conversation page
those are specifically things that look
like the backend of automating this this
sum this thing but I'm still trying to
understand in the cloud how do we
connect to a particular channel ego you
understand my question so in other words
if we have a channel that corresponds to
a chat session right which is operating
on a particular channel with particular
UUID and
then in an IP I function channel listen
does not make sense for now because
channel listen implies that there is a
kernel is do I get triggered task is
supposed to be trigger about on a
channel but it's the analog of scheduled
tasks but it triggers when there is data
received on a channel yes yes yes yes
right so that's the analog it's not a
great name given given that that's the
analog of essentially a channel what is
it I mean it's a channel API function or
something right well I mean I don't know
anything about the trigger task thing
but how we would implement this now I
think is you know under the hood each
one of these chat channels has a channel
receiver function attached to it and
that channel channel receiver functions
right now all it does is provides you
know for a chatroom it provides the
stored messages you know if you join a
chatroom that's already in progress you
know so it but it does run an API to do
that if we couldn't you know attach
another a bot API to that channel
receiver function which then when that
channel receives something it passes it
along to this API look I mean the fact
is it's very much like mail receiver
function if you deploy a mail receiver
function then what happens is you're
given a mail handle and anything that is
sent to that mail handle is sent to the
mail receiver function so similarly
in this case what we want is that
anything that is sent to this chat is
sent to some kind of chat receiver
function
well you can do it with the channel
receiver function it triggers a cloud
object execution on each and every
message send sense to the channel but
what is it in the cloud the channel
receiver function is that operating in
the cloud it executes basically a cloud
object
so whatever cloud object can execute
it's done okay let's walk through this
again
okay we start a chat maybe we started
with our friendly bot already in the
chat or part way along people say oh I
really want to ask about that question
let's add that bot
think those are the two obvious
scenarios
and and in fact the way a bot is going
to look in the original thing where
you're selecting users okay so the next
question is does the bots have a wolfram
ID
because that will be the analog of male
receiver function which after all you
are
how does that work male receiver
function
is a generic email address with one of
those plus things to disambiguate which
mail receiver function it's going to
whereas in this case okay so one could
imagine a similar thing for these BOTS
right I mean if I deploy a mail receiver
function thing if I say something like
let's go here um
if I say cloud deploy mail receive a
function of and see what can I say I can
say hash string reverse of hash subject
I think
you
and
should happen why is it taking so long
there we go okay there it is
right so if I then send mail
to that receiver function oh it's not
gonna do anything very exciting right
because it's gonna say right all that's
all this is going to do is it's going to
in the privacy of its own cloud it's
going to evaluate string of us which
isn't going to do anything that I can
see by making sense yeah if I said send
mail of that deploy that
then let's try here then I say hello
there and hopefully
it will send me stiff that worked very
good
magnificent there it is okay so let's
understand the analogy of that for a bot
right because imagine that we did a chat
receiver function here
and then what would happen is that we
would get back
what would we get back some kind of fake
wolfram ID I'd just like this is sort of
a fake wool from ID
I'm making sense and you could then add
that wolf my D to your chat session and
just like the male receiver function it
would allow you to interact with the
thing
let's make sense to people yeah now can
you name those male receiver functions
and what sense name well the you know
that you map b:g 87 it you know can you
the left no I don't believe so at this
time because this is this has to be
hooked in this is to do with the whole
service deploy business this is hooking
into a mail system right hooking into
the mail system that operates in the
cloud and that receiver plus whatever is
in the in the actual they know excuse me
in the actual mail processor that plus
thing is getting stripped off and is
getting used to determine which actual
cloud object there's then a table that's
telling it which cloud object to use and
so on
sure for for well I mean I'm what I'm
getting at is that if you're making
these BOTS presumably you'd want to be
able to name them something yes you
would like to name them and but we've
got to have some notation then I mean
maybe you name them as a cloud object in
your okay so we got to figure out how to
do that we got to figure out how to add
a non okay if it is something other than
well from ID how you add a non wolfram
ID you know in here when you save you
participants right somewhere here there
would also be a bot
Yeah right indicate it somehow okay look
I think we need
separate designer meeting about this
channel about this chat stuff we're now
talking about the whole channel system
and the question is this is all
considered experimental at this time and
you know I feel very unconfident of what
we have here at this point but I don't
know maybe maybe ego can convince me
otherwise I mean I feel like it's no I I
don't want to convince you otherwise my
intention is to make it 2d experimental
eyes when we have other protocols except
now we have only one polling and I think
that we must have at least WebSockets
omggg or some other protocol stop this
this channel would exist
what is Lisbon it's a channel object I
can see that yeah yes so so what's the
question what is it
what does it have what is chat
invitations it's created all objects
that created in your crease created in
your name by the chat system it's yeah
sorry that's the when you when I say
invite you to a chat yeah it's some kind
of healing threatening yeah that's
exactly what it is yeah okay all right
so and if I say channel base here that
will just be the channel broker yes in
the cloud yes and somewhat obscurely if
I go to the channel broker in it's an
HTTP channel broker but if this was mqtt
would that look different have another
IP address but right now that just goes
to this yeah sorry must have an HTTP for
an end because not every system in the
world communicates on MQTT protocol so
for example if you want to get messages
from Facebook or some other service
which does not support them PDT it has
to have an HTTP Frenette okay okay so
we'll look the same man that this will
be this front-end will be the same ole
it's a channel broker 11.com slash MQTT
or something although we may eventually
move it to that IP address and do some
separation of labor well I don't
understand the the if the thing is being
pointed to a publish subscribe channel
broker it's gotta have a definite I mean
what our internal protocol is you're
saying many of the external services are
just gonna use HTTP yes
okay but they're not internally to us we
can be using MQTT but then this there is
a translator somewhere that's brokering
to http
correction
okay
someone is asking is there a way to get
the channel broker pub/sub system
working locally without the cloud
yes at the moment we do not distribute
our server but we can do it at some
point there's any good reason we don't
distribute the server no it just
requires a little bit of cleanup I mean
are we eventually going to just put the
server on github or something I mean it
is the server the server is a pretty
generic channel brokering server right
yes yes we run on any device whether
it's a a seriously you know whether it
has our engine or not most definitely
the server does not use our engine per
se the server runs in whatever language
you want it to run currently it's it's
it runs in no GS but it can run in go it
can run in any other Dublin right but
but and what it's doing is fairly
trivial right well it's a pops up
mechanism I would not call it real but
yes it's very generic right another
question here from the live stream can
we run the channel open function from
well from session running in a server be
helpful for IOT applications or any pub
sub application what does that mean so
the channel open function there is no
channel open function there is create
channel channel isn't channel send but
what the user means by joining them in
create channel okay okay so create
channel
is running that is creating a channel to
own the channel base on that channel
basis right mm-hmm okay so what would
that look like if that was a local
server it will be a different HTTP
address why does that have an HTTP
address at all I mean if you're on a
local machine there's no so does the
thing include a web server what does the
channel broker include a web server well
of course the channel broker runs in a
web server which is implemented note yes
so it is a web server in in a sense okay
so what you're saying is in order to run
this locally right in order to run you
know this on an arbitrary machine you
basically need you're setting up
something which is effectively a web
server yes yes yes okay fine but but so
so if that was the case then when you
set up the web server to set up a web
server you need to define some kind of
address yes and if you have DNS and all
that then it gets it's kind of a
complicated thing have an IP address so
long as it's reachable it's more
straightforward
but to set up the DNS stuff I mean
that's for example in the private cloud
that's a whole you know you know whole
page of setup has to do with that whole
thing I'm not mistaken so what you are
likely to see will you to do this
locally just you and they give yeah but
your channel base would be an IP address
is that correct yes and then there's an
API before the channel for the pub/sub
server effectively that says create a
new channel is that right
yes in the in the server yes it creates
in you Channel yes and what about the
administration of that server like for
example our cloud server is as
administration which presumably prevents
too many channels from staying open for
too long and all that kind of thing
oh well we do provide some rate limiting
and channel limiting so yes right but
that's all Do It Yourself situation for
somebody with a local or a okay but so
it seems to me that allowing people to
download instances of our but by the way
another question I mean I assume that
there isn't some standard channel broker
out there which we simply interoperate
with but you just say download this
channel broker oh well the idea behind
that mqtt server was exactly that to use
the standard pops up server and
embellish it with some of stuff that is
specific to go from that Beach
um oh that's interesting somebody's
sending a link to Mathematica Stack
Exchange about running Mathematica on
docker and it's interesting
interesting I know is that from an
internal person or is that from an
outside person who's got um I have to
admit in in the spectrum of how easy is
it to do this this is not super
encouraging to me the number of steps
required here
you
Wow okay well it's cool that's great
oh this was some this was like just
posted today that's really cool I know
we've had an internal project to look at
docker docker ization of this but yeah
if there's a way to to build the stuff
in a docker container that would be nice
I think um
okay so someone's pointing
as the child if the create channel work
locally then it can bind to local silver
port like in the above docker thing
which will also solve privacy problems
that come with the cloud yeah I agree
yeah I agree
now but
but I guess one of the questions is so I
think what we're what we're hearing here
is a call for for actually getting this
our pub/sub server to be downloadable by
people what what's involved in that well
we need to clean up the cold we need to
if you're happy with the long curl with
a long polling protocol only then we
just need to clean up this well I mean
look one protocol is better than no
protocols yes it's not the best protocol
I mean what's it what are the other ones
that we are there's that web-based I
mean some that that's the the WebSockets
thing is no - yes yes WebSocket and M K
DT would be very nice both WebSockets
for communicating with bed size with
social media sighs well in all these
cases were you know it's it's great for
our community to help contribute these
things and if we put this you know if we
can provide the code for the for the
HTTP version then you know that's a
really good start and and maybe people
can contribute the versions for these
other which will be plug compatible yes
I mean there's nothing or or are you
saying that's not the case is it is
there additional if the server uses a
different protocol what support do we
have to have to make that vertical work
what support we have to have outside of
the observer itself well we need to
communication we need to communicate to
ensure channel options are passed
correctly but that is currently in
development we may be able to separate
the server protocol from other channel
options protocol this is what I am doing
right now okay but but so what I'm
trying to understand the documentation
that we have over on the left for
channel based communication how much of
it has to change if we support web
sockets or MQTT ideally nothing but that
is exactly the point I am making we need
to verify that it changes nothing and
then we can do experimental eyes the
same okay but one thing that would
change is to our channel base it's not
not correctly yes of course but channel
base is ideally user configurable thing
but what okay if I'm not mistaken so
you're saying the channel base
identifies that channel base is somehow
Gateway through things through to HTTP
I'm very confused how does it know
something like channel send ultimately a
bunch of bits get sent out you know to
some port on some server correct
okay what determines I mean that pattern
of bits is different from qtt and HTTP
how is the pattern of bits formed that
is the job of the end of the channel
framework client so that the client will
understand what needs to be done for the
it's going to do negotiation with the
server to figure out what the server can
accept at the first that first instance
we will have a definition of the server
which will say that a server and this
address understands this protocol
is the address an IP address or is they
address some kind of DNS you know look
yes
it's an IP address okay so fine so how
does it know if the thing you know 10.10
dot whatever it is how does it know that
that is an mqtt server there is in the
work in the developments there is a
surveyor definition file which will say
that server at this address understands
this type of where the definition file
going it can be loaded like any
mathematical from language file
that's not a good answer because I'm
also it goes it goes with the channel
framework for user for our defined so it
goes with the channel framework the
client but if you're not to be load it
from any user file if you saw what way
way sideways it was it was it so you're
saying if I do channel sand right now if
I say channel send I would say channel
send to like percent six and I would say
hello yes and you can add the channel
base option if you want and it will send
it to a channel but if that was an MQTT
if that was a broker expecting MQTT what
would this look like it will be exactly
the same provided that you don't dollar
channel for a dollar Channel base is
pointing to an entity compatible but how
does it know that it's an mqtt
compatible server because channel base
might just be you know 10.10 dot dot 200
or something okay so the current design
is that we have a channel a server
definition file so when children work
loads it looks up what servers are
available how does it how can it look
that up how does it know how are these
are the service broadcasting something
or it looks it looks in predefined
places don't know what the predefined
places are mean if you just created in
the client like how can you do that if
you're setting up your own web server
there's no guarantee where that would
end up going right or is it going to
some local host where is it going
I mean I don't know how this works the
reason internal can come and add the
server definition the I I forgot the
name exactly it's in the development
but if you loaded the framework with the
default server or servers and then he
wants to add another one you go just
execute that command at the server Eid
channel framework seems like the wrong
way to do it I mean we've got a channel
base why does the channel base not say
what the server I don't know what the
right thing to do is here but I mean for
example why does the channel base not
become something like you know address
blah blah blah protocol blah blah blah
it's an interesting idea because yeah we
have a cloud base which does not have
these so we understand what we don't
have a protocol there's no protocol
issue for the cloud right right right
but all of a base function do we have a
precedent for a X base function at all
to have an association
well we we're about to have system
servers is about to have such a thing
system servers will have a lot of
complicated configuration stuff for each
server and doing its authentication
information and so on so I don't think
that's that Brad would know Ashley would
know about that okay I'll make a note
because that is an interesting idea
instead of agent server definitions
somewhere else just added to the channel
base to the base definition someone with
handle see I don't even know how to
parse these handles turbo call hard to
know whether that's a it could be dub it
could be many different things so I'm
not even going to try but anyway on our
live stream says if we can do the
channel framework locally available then
its handler function can be further link
to a Redis fact server
great performance why yeah because you
can put the the messages into Redis
presumably
and this business is encouraging us to
get this ready for the next version
thank you for the encouragement um there
but but I I still just want to go
through one more time and we should we
should wrap up soon but I want to go
through one more time how this would
actually work so what you're saying is
we have currently okay we currently have
this web server based channel broker
that's sitting in our cloud at this no
an address easy and in a private cloud
part of the private cloud configuration
is to determine that address well in the
private cloud we can define a different
different channel base yeah obviously
but but my question how do we pick up
how does the desktop client for example
the desktop client I see this Cloud
Connect determine the channel base
independent because you can around
different clouds against the same
channel broker and vice versa but so
there has to be some mechanism and it
may have to work through the system
service mechanism whereby the desktop
client and it also relates to persistent
values in the cloud the desktop client
has to be able to pick up the you know
as to have an easy way to pick up the
addresses of things like channel brokers
that's a that's an issue for the system
service business but okay let's come
back to this so somebody takes the
existing nodejs server and puts it in
some random place in their IT
infrastructure and it's freely possible
to do that okay
so then they would either hook it up to
have a particular address but the thing
that our system doesn't know is that
thing that that address is expecting
HTTP right yes HTTP I understand that I
understand but in the future
the question is how do you know okay
here's a super naive question I mean
maybe I'm confused about something here
don't you have to give a port number for
I mean in other words if it's gonna use
some protocol I mean isn't you know port
80 is what you would expect the web
server to use if I'm not mistaken HTTP
and HTTPS have the default ports but you
can infect in channel base if it's for
example listening on a non-standard form
you can just add the column and your
port no I understand but but my question
is to know that it's age that it's using
MQTT this MQTT have a standard port yes
and mqts
they also have a different port but we
will have to have this protocol
identification somewhere is in channel
bridge it's obviously in
is the channel brick okay so yeah we
need to specify it in channel base
because the channel object wait a minute
the channel object is refers to a
channel base right every channel object
refers to a channel base is it totally
obvious why is it a protocol not part of
the channel object it can be it can be
as an option yes okay
I think we have to we have to wrap this
particular meeting but this okay I think
we're going to need a separate
discussion but I think one thing that's
come out of this is the importance of
getting the existing server the existing
channel broker server prepped before
release and that release could be
asynchronous if I'm not mistaken that
could be asynchronous from the version
release because it's basically just
being put out as a downloadable thing
that people can install wherever they
want indeed correct yes so so
but nevertheless the thing that still
has to be established is you know how do
I identify what type of channel broker
it is and so on okay yes yes it's in the
development but you have not seen it yet
discuss it at some point okay sounds
good
all right I think that so the basic
conclusion is channel stuff has to be
[Music]
um it has to be the left experimental
someone is asking here do you need
channel basis Annette to function which
would set all the parameters protocols
ports yeah the problem is that the
reason this is kind of a mess is that
everybody I mean maybe the better way to
do this okay I've got a better idea
yes every channel broker needs a
configuration file
it's very least saying what protocol
it's using but maybe it needs other
information I don't know if it does
maybe the channel broker should be
proxied through maybe the configuration
of the channel broker should be proxied
through a cloud object which could be
then share because one of the issues is
you know a typical pub/sub connection
you know there are there are two sides
to it so to speak and it's no good you
know you can have all the fancy connect
you know information you want but
something the reason you're using it is
because something else is communicating
with it and that information also needs
to be given to the other thing did that
make sense mm-hmm so for instance I mean
a typical other end of that
communication channel would be something
in the in the data drop world if I'm not
mistaken
it could be now the current channel
broker has a channel I forgot
xhl channel broker action function which
can direct your messages to data drop no
I'm asking a different question so when
you connect things to data drop right
you connect you know a random electric
in to data drop
what is the OIC that's just a direct
connection to data drop that's not going
through the channel framework no what
was that what's the connection between
the channel but there are devices which
one to use pub/sub right so how does
that work
this is there a generic pub/sub
connection for data drop I believe not
but data drop cancer ethically redirect
messages to the channel broker if you
want no no but I'm asking a question I
would have no I would approach it from
the other end if for your i io g device
wants to pass messages through the
channel broker instead of data drop
because data drop is designed to store
messages permanently or semi-permanently
so if you want your clients to process
messages from your IOT device you would
just route that messages through an HTTP
request currently in to our channel
blocker server and that's it you just
need to execute an HTTP request on the
IOT device side and your messages will
go automatically to our system and from
language clower clients can receive
these messages or some cloud function
can be executed just like you do with
the api request
okay we should wrap up here um all right
thanks everybody thanks particularly to
the folks on the livestream lots of very
interesting good and encouraging
comments okay see y'all soon
yep thanks bye bye